hello welcome to las vegas' side in
spanish your digital connection to the world of
entertainment here in las vegas
greets you natalia maintained today we start
talking about the line grammys and the
countdown to this night of
celebration for latin music is
only weeks away  to happen and with this the
iconic singer and former accident in
hollywood christina aguilera confirmed her
presentation during the
award ceremony cristiano will perform
with the killing mic and nicole and nati
pelusso will present
his new single to the world of him rather to the world
called my boys
the grammy awards ceremonies
will take place here in las vegas on
thursday november 18 at the mgm grand
garden harina
bueno and this weekend you can
enjoy live music from one of
the nominees for the grammys you  I'm
talking about the Colombian Carol and she
will be presenting herself on Twitter inside the
Virgin Hotel this Saturday starting at
8 p.m.  e there are still tickets
available through excel dotcom
good for rock lovers the
rolling stones are coming to law in
stereo also this weekend the
show is on saturday and the doors of the
stadium will open at 6 pm and the
concert will start at 8
pm there are still resale tickets
available at ticketmaster.com
and speaking of rockers the band keys have
canceled their hollywood presidency
which should have
started in december until february
2022 we still don't know the  reason behind
this news but will keep you posted
as more details come to light
meanwhile lionel richie announced an
extension to his show in the wind so is the
legendary singer damaged added 12
new dates that will take place from january to
april 2022 tickets go out  the sale
this Friday,
well, let's change the subject and talk about
the holidays and the fact is that the great return of
the chocolate shop and its
Christmas lights in the cactus garden are
already  They are here they will open their doors to the
public this Friday but be careful you must
make a reservation before
attending this event and keep in mind
that they will ask you for a minimum donation of 5
dollars in which it would benefit 34
food bank for more information visit
this at dotcom
and  Werner Lights announced its return to Las
Vegas Motor Speedway on Friday,
November 12. Tickets for this
two-mile-plus wonder of Christmas
lights are $25 per vehicle
and speaking of the holiday season, get
your ice skates ready because the
Cosmopolitan Ice Rink  returns to las
vegas' for its tenth consecutive year
this track will open its doors on tuesday
november 16 until january 2 of
next year well and before saying goodbye
I leave you with something that you can enjoy with your
family in the truck the barbie doll
will be  now more of a stop at
downtown summer link as part of their
national tour you can check it out
that saturday starting at
10am good  not until you arrived saying in las
vegas' nao in spanish don't forget to
visit a dotcom on this set you
need more information about these
events thank you very much for your attention
we will give you next week's greetings
natalia bad sound
[Music]